the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC well welcome everybody I hope you
had a great weekend it was an insane
weekend of political happenings and news
and events and I want to start with two
examples of anti-woke backfires now
later in the program we'll get back into
the perversion of the term woke we don't
have to do that here but we're first
going to talk about one of these
anti-woke book bands completely and
totally backfiring I told you weeks ago
that in Utah there was already an
attempt made to ban the Bible from
public school libraries
specifically because of the rule that
right Wingers put in place about violent
and sexual content in books and indeed
that has now succeeded in some schools
NPR reports a Utah school district has
removed the Bible from the school from
some schools shelves frustrated with
book challenges and bands in their
school district a parent in Utah
submitted a complaint of their own about
the Bible
now good for the Davis School District
they took the objection objection
seriously they placed the Bible under
review and the district officially
decided to remove the religious text
from elementary and middle school
libraries for containing vulgarity or
violence the ban takes effect
immediately with Bibles being removed
from classrooms even as they close down
for the summer Additionally the Book of
Mormon is now under review as a result
of the exact same thing so let's talk
about what's going on here the Utah book
ban by right Wingers is a case of
censorship backfiring the ban was hoping
to block
the normal The Usual Suspects right
books on lgbtq plus topics or by certain
authors of a particular identity racial
issues
ETC but what it has led to because of
how it is written violent content sexual
content the Bible is filled with violent
and sexual content it has led to the
Bible being removed for violence and sex
this shows a number of different
important characteristics of this
movement that we are now seeing number
one their hypocrisy because all of the
right Wingers who said we like the rule
opposed the removal of the Bible and
we've confronted some of them on the
show and they call in ETC and we say
well hold on a second if these are the
rules if this is the standard if this is
the barometer the checklist violent
content sexual content here it is in the
Bible here's examples of violence in the
Bible here's examples of sexual content
in the Bible on it so many of them they
say well that's different
well okay in what way is it different
they can't really articulate any
difference other than they don't want
the Bible removed the ban is also part
of this lar so it's arbitrary it's
capricious it's hypocritical the ban is
also part really of a larger trend from
the right of censorship while claiming
the other side is doing the censoring
and then using lawmakers and government
to achieve that very censorship of which
they accuse the other side I am against
book bands for a number of different
reasons number one they are taking
teachers out of the decisions as to what
materials are appropriate for children
of what age and putting it in the hands
of parents parents whose expertise is
not education whose expertise is not
literature whose expertise is not a
child development
so we're saying let's give people who
are less qualified the ability to decide
what is in school libraries they silence
authors
they silence Librarians they they damage
the trust and the dialogue between
schools and communities and also they
can have the very corrosive effect of
tying schools up not only in protests
but in legal challenges that's not good
for anybody that's not good for learning
as a progressive right I'm a progressive
I'm not for censorship
I I have to pause there I know the right
says we are the ones wanting to censor
no no no no I'm a progressive I believe
in the power of books to educate Empower
and empathize I believe in the power of
reading to develop vocabulary language
knowledge
Etc I want to let teachers decide
what's appropriate at which age maintain
separation of church and state meaning
the Bible gets no special status
and when it comes to teaching religious
texts I'm not against teaching religious
texts but they shouldn't be in science
class they should be taught as religious
texts maybe in comparative comparative
religion class or something like that
probably not to second graders would be
my sense in a public school so I oppose
book bands and I oppose the book bands
based on uh ideology and morality and
Common Sense and all these other things
I'm glad to have a dialogue I'm glad to
collaborate with teachers to determine
what are the appropriate texts at
different ages we might say you know I I
remember
I think it was second grade when our
teacher would read Roll of Thunder Hear
My Cry a book that in its unabridged
version contains the n-word it contains
violence about slavery Etc was it
inappropriate for second graders I don't
think so I remember being riveted
horrified to learn about the treatment
of slaves and the legacy of slavery and
all these things could you come out and
say you know that's probably really
better for like third graders or fourth
graders sure I mean listen these are
reasonable discussions saying we're
going to ban the book no I don't think
so so I stand with the anti-censorship
groups the student groups the teacher
groups Etc they are a threat and now
what we are seeing is this backfire on
themselves in Utah as the Bible has been
banned in some places The Book of Mormon
is now on The Chopping Block this is the
monster they created they have no one to
blame but themselves another major
defeat for the anti-woke clowns this
time it is that drag ban ruled
unconstitutional
this is the beautiful detail Folks by a
trump appointed judge the Tennessee
anti-drag Bill violates free speech and
expression it's too broad and too vague
the Associated Press has a great report
on this Tennessee's first in the nation
law designed to place strict limits on
drag shows is unconstitutional a federal
judge says the law is both quote
unconstitutionally vague and
substantially overbroad and encourages
discriminatory enforcement according to
the ruling late Friday by U.S District
Judge Thomas Parker appointed by failed
former president Donald Trump quote
there is no question that obscenity is
not protected by the First Amendment but
there's a difference between material
that is obscene in the vernacular and
material that is obscene under the law
simply put no majority of the Supreme
Court has held that sexually explicit
but not obscene speech receives less
protection than political artistic or
scientific scientific speech said the
judge the article also says the law
would have banned adult Cabaret
performances from public property or
anywhere miners might be present
performers who broke the law risked
being charged with a misdemeanor or a
felony for a repeat offense this is a
Bonkers law it deserved to be taken down
and so far that is the decision now will
it be appealed we will see but we knew
you know it it's funny it's important to
let legal Scholars and jurists weigh in
on these things but we could all see
that the use of the word obscenity was
being used not as it is required to be
used under the law but just colloquially
oh that's obscene I don't know I see a
picture of a drag performer that's
obscene and that's my opinion that's not
legally obscene and that's actually what
matters here and good for the Trump
appointed judge for pointing that out
the bill is vague it's broad it doesn't
really Define what is an adult Cabaret
performance what is a male impersonator
it leaves room for arbitrary enforcement
discriminatory enforcement but the most
important thing is listen the first
obstacle is let's get a legal opinion
that shows the nuts and bolts of this
Tennessee anti-drag Bill are ridiculous
that's step one
step two let's remember that it is again
being pushed by Hypocrites Tennessee
governor Bill Lee who previously dressed
in drag now says this is a danger to our
children and this is the law we need so
they are hypocrites legally problematic
hypocritical but the zoom out the thirty
thousand foot
is that this one bill is just a part of
the larger wave of the anti-lgbt
legislation that we're seeing in many
right-wing States it's targeting trans
youth it's Banning gender affirming care
it's limiting access to bathrooms it's
doing all sorts of different things and
it's all motivated by the rights saying
now it is trans people who are the
scapegoats for a long time it was gay
men maybe for like a week it was
lesbians they never really were too
worked up about lesbians for a while it
was gay men and now they're shifting
over to saying the problem is trans
people and it's motivated by fear it's
motivated by misinformation it depends
on stereotypes and myths about remember
the first it was The Stereotype and myth
of the gay man as the pedophile
didn't make any sense but gay men are
interested in other gay men who have
gone through puberty we're not talking
about pedophilia now they're applying
that to trans people uh people are going
to say oh I put on a wig and now I'm a
woman so I can hit on little girls in a
bathroom that's already illegal doesn't
matter which bathroom you're in
already against the law don't need any
new laws to prevent that and it also
essentially never happens and
um they're now targeting drag shows to
completely benign we interviewed a drag
performer a few weeks ago who was very
articulately able to explain the
absurdity of all of this so the Hope
here is that if this decision is
appealed it will be upheld uh not that
the bill will be upheld that the
unconstitutionality of banning drag
shows will be upheld and this is again
another one of these issues where the
right now is saying look at all of these
leftists wanting to die on the hill of
drag shows we're not the ones who
started this thing we're just saying the
law should be uh enforced and the Bills
should be the laws should be evaluated
for their constitutionality it is
because of the right making this an
issue that this is an issue left Wingers
weren't going around saying let's go
around creating a defenses for drag
shows and for as long as the right keeps
pushing these nonsense laws My Hope Is
um that the left and sane thinking
jurists are going to do what needs to be
done to point out that the laws are not
only hypocritical capricious and
unnecessary uh but also unconstitutional
in the way that this one is let's take a
very quick break make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube at youtube.com the
davidpackman show we are powering
towards
1.75 million YouTube subscribers which
will put us within that final 250
000 subscriber push to 2 million be a
part of it we'll take a quick break and
be right back
if you are still looking for the perfect
Father's Day gift check this out guys
know that it can be tough to find good
boxers and t-shirts but the search can
end now because our sponsor Leisure of
NYC sells the most comfortable t-shirts
and boxers that your dad is ever going
to wear all boxer briefs by Leisure of
NYC are made with amazingly soft
moisture wicking viscose from bamboo
feels lightweight like air but it
doesn't Bunch up it's also better for
the planet Leisure of NYC also makes
these incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's really the best out
there it just feels almost like Silk you
can let your dad walk around in a
scratchy t-shirt all day but come on you
can also treat him with the cloud soft
feel of supine cotton so that it'll
actually love the shirt these are always
my go-to shirts and boxers no other
company even comes close to the Comfort
they provide and all of their products
are fair trade and made sustainably go
to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below
we really are now as you will shortly
see in the midst of the 2024 election
the Republican primary is rapidly
getting completely out of control and
cartoonish and humiliating fashion and
that's why you can use the coupon code
24 starts now when you sign up for a
membership at joinpakman.com you'll get
a sizable discount and it will be a
beautiful day when you sign up on our
website we are primarily supported by
members in all seriousness you know the
daily wires arguing over 50 million
dollar contracts they've got millionaire
donors it's Bonkers what's going on the
left doesn't have that and if you
checked out the recent NBC news article
written about the David packman show one
of the topics is the left doesn't have
that sort of donation infrastructure
from Rich mostly dudes right I mean
let's be Frank from from these rich
white dudes that pour money into the
daily wire uh we don't have that and so
we depend on folks who sign up at
joinpakman.com I hope you'll do that you
can read about the great member benefits
on our website we are going to look at
weekend campaign events involving Ron
DeSantis Ron de sanctimonious
um Nikki Haley uh who else uh we'll get
to Pence we're going to start with Trump
Donald Trump had a town hall event on
Fox News in Iowa the event was so bad so
humiliating that even the friendliest of
friendly Fox News hosts Sean Hannity
could not save Donald Trump if you want
to see what a cult looks like it's Trump
entering the room to this
okay
okay so those are cult members as you
can see I'm finishing up Vincent
bugliosi's book about the prosecution of
the Manson Murders many many many many
many many many many
similarities between uh the family as
Manson's followers were called and
Trump's followers Trump bringing up uh I
mean listen I dare I'm not even going to
tell you what he brings up because I
don't know I dare you to decode this
clip from Trump during the town hall
oh boy
and the clip is glitching badly let's
hope we don't have this this would
become a humiliating segment hold on
here we go then your soldiers believe me
that's going to be like the greatest
deal you've ever made is to give us the
28 000 and they gave us 20 at that 8 000
soldiers free of charge and they stop
people you know they have no rules that
you're not allowed to talk fresh to
somebody or they put you in jail for the
rest of your life these soldiers are
tough soldiers in that sense so are ours
but our soldiers are told to do things
that are horrible I am it's I'm as
clueless as you are about what he's
talking about if you speak a little
there and you go back to some
and be able to be thrown out of the
military how about Patton you used to
slap slap them around you get out there
and you three people clapping about
patent slapping people
she would have been out within two days
he would have been out of the military
uh look we've gone we've gone so bad
it's it's so sad what's happened yep
okay completely unintelligible word
salads and the crowd just cheers for
anything anything he says the crowd
cheers for Trump did make an interesting
claim Trump says that he uh got CNN to
do his town hall at 8 instead of nine
specifically to not compete with his
friend Sean Hannity and take away
ratings isn't that something you get
their best rating in 11 years that's
pretty good you know normally normally
if you do that you have a success so
they got their best ratings and they
want to fire the head of CNN so it's
supposed to everything is like April
Fool's Day nowadays right you get good
ratings you're supposed to get a bonus
right and you know what I did I said
I'll do the show but I'm not going
against Sean Hannity is that correct
that's why I was on at eight o'clock
they had me at nine I said wait a minute
nine but John's on Nine I said nope I'm
not doing it this well then we'll throw
it off I said I don't care they wanted
to do it I didn't want to do it they
said we'll do it at eight now how nice
is that right there you go nice little
favor to Sean Hannity and as with most
of these stories number one completely
irrelevant to whether Trump would
improve this country as president and
number two we never know whether these
stories are fabricated whole cloth or
whether there's even a grain of Truth to
them Trump reacting to Ron DeSantis
claiming he'll have eight years to
improve the country Trump's saying you
really don't need eight years I only
need six months people say oh you can't
it's just like
when I hear the Sanctus when I hear the
sanctimonious come and say we need eight
years
again if he needs eight years don't vote
for him I'll have that this country will
be hopping in six months and a lot of
it's going to do with energy
it'll be hot for it in six months unless
you know what's funny Trump could become
president and then on the day of the
inauguration January 2025 if the economy
looks like it looks now Trump will just
point to the existing numbers he'll say
look unemployment's so low black
unemployment so low wages are up
inflation's down stock market steady
there is no of course the economy will
be hopping in six months
because the economy is doing fine right
now could we have a recession a
depression of course we always could but
this idea that it's a disaster and Trump
will fix it laughable laughable idea
Trump then pulls out this claim that
he'll end the ukraine-russia war in 24
hours Hannity actually says how will you
do it and as you can see very shaky
Trump's going Trump's got the talking
point down I'll end the war in 24 hours
he needs to figure out what to say when
people ask him how will you do that but
I want to stop the War I don't want that
war to continue and I'll stop that war
mark my words I'll stop that war in 24
hours
but we're in a position
the only way he could stop in 24 hours
would be to force Ukraine to fold I
can't think of any other way he could
end it in 24 hours
[Applause]
how do you stop that war in 24 hours I
know both and frankly uh zielinski was
very good because they you know he was
part of the phone call and he said he
didn't say anything wrong to me the
Democrat he could have gone in
grandstand and said well I felt
threatened I felt threatened he didn't
I get along with him I get along with
Putin it's it would have been much
easier to stop it before it started
Putin would have never done this would
have been much easier right now it's a
mess now they're hitting Kiev and
they're hitting all sorts of things that
weren't supposed to be hit right the
country is being decimated by the way
the deaths are far more than their
report you know when they say nine if
you're waiting for the answer it's not
in here an apartment houses got knocked
down and two people got hurt there's no
no hundreds of people died the the
numbers are much different than what
you're being told I will get them into a
room and they will and I know an exact
way number one you tell one
you're not going to get anything unless
you make a deal you tell the other one
they're going to get a lot unless you
make a deal and you just sit them and
you put them and you have to make a
determination
and I'm telling you the crowd convinced
by this completely unintelligible
meaningless explanation from Trump as to
how he will broker peace between Ukraine
and Russia within 24 hours Trump also
during this deranged Town Hall taking
credit for ending Roe v Wade which by
the way was not a very popular change
with the majority of Americans I don't
know that I'd be bragging about this
this might be why Republicans didn't do
so well in the 2022 midterms I didn't
think when I started my radio career in
1987 I'd be talking a lot about but uh
education kids gender identity classes
CRT uh I never thought we'd really have
this deep debate about whether or not
biological men could be playing in
women's sports when you so crazy on all
of these issues you know what is the
best way that you see to settle well I
did something that nobody thought was
possible I get rid of Roe v Wade and by
doing that
[Applause]
it puts pro-lifers in a very strong
negotiating position now they're
negotiating different things and you
know I happen to be of the Ronald Reagan
School in terms of uh exemptions where
you have the life of the mother rape and
Princess mother's life so you have that
and I think you know for me that's
something that works very well and for
probably 80 85 percent because don't
forget we do have to win elections but I
did something that nobody could do and I
also made them the radicals because they
are willing and able to kill babies in
the ninth month they're willing to kill
babies that's radical pro-life isn't
radical okay so this is crazy stuff of
course it's all untrue but I if I were
Trump I don't know that I'd be bragging
about ending Roe v Wade given the
unpopularity of that decision and then
lastly here is Trump again
unintelligible I guess talking about
documents uh and Chinatown I don't know
I mean these these rants really are
putting uh putting linguists through
their Paces I have the right to
declassify as president he's got 18
pictures that he doesn't want anyone to
see he had seven or eight boxes in
Chinatown in Washington DC where nobody
even speaks English in Chinatown
Chinatown is very it's it's in favor of
China yeah
Chinatown is it's in favor of China so
even with the most friendly questions
almost no pushback other than like oh
like how would you end the war in 24
hours Trump unable to coherently put
together a policy Vision there's nothing
he's not articulating any policy Vision
other than the sanctimonious is bad and
Joe Biden's bad and so on and so forth
now if you thought that the fox Town
Hall was bad
just wait until you see Trump's speeches
over the weekend in Iowa
failed former president Donald Trump
gave a number of speeches in different
parts of the state of Iowa and early
state in the primary process and an
important state he gave a speech in
Urbandale he gave a speech in Des Moines
he gave a speech in Grimes and
potentially others as well uh now I mean
it's almost automatically satirical
the crowd chanting USA when Trump enters
[Applause]
well I want to thank you this was a
little bit of a surprise for you I heard
but there you go Trump's surprising the
crowd and the crowd chanting USA one of
the claims Trump made during these
events was that we need to bring
religion back into the country now that
may come as a surprise to those who
realize not only has religion not left
the country we still have religious
influence in Government at the state and
federal level you regularly hear
religious arguments made during Civil
policy debates when it comes to abortion
or gay marriage or whatever the case may
be many of us wondering why is there so
much religion given that we're supposed
to have separation of church and state
Trump says we have to bring religion
back and we have to bring religion back
into our country because that's
something that's
that's something that is as you know
it's under uh it's under attack a lot of
us are under attack and we uh We're not
gonna we're gonna win we're gonna win
big we're gonna win bigger than ever
before just uh yep bigger than ever
before we're gonna bring religion back
people wondering where did it go it
seems to be very front and center a
hilarious moment Fox News dipped into
Trump's speeches at one point and right
when uh anchor Harris Faulkner cuts to
Trump in Urbandale Iowa Trump is
defending the January 6 rioters this is
always a risk if you cut into a live
Trump speech he could be defending
anyone and in this particular case fox
goes over and Trump is defending the
rioters Trump is speaking at the West
Side conservative breakfast in Urbandale
Iowa right now let's watch what happens
to these people and then you look at
what they've done to the January six
people they've destroyed them and
destroyed their lives and a lot of them
didn't even go into the building it was
a disgrace what's going on that is it
whoops let's cut away does disgrace
that's that's going to go down in
history ultimately and Ashley Babbitt
was killed shot by uh in my opinion a
rogue cop he had no business doing that
he shot her shot unarmed and actually
people say she was trying to hold back
the people that were pushing her forward
she was a good Samaritan there I mean of
course the investigation into that
shooting didn't find any of that
evidence but she was a good Samaritan
suddenly the officer was in the wrong
say the always defend the police people
Ashley Babbitt was the one that was
killed she was the one that was killed
and uh they like to say five people
that's the truth is and there will
happen to be somebody else also in
addition to Ashley but Ashley Babbitt
was a big supporter of everybody in this
room and there you go by every account
she was an incredible person and a great
Patriot and he shot her like just like
he had no problem and then yeah so not
exactly the best moment for Fox News to
care Harry Trump speech Trump then
complained many people who used the term
woke can't Define it now I want you to
remember this moment because we're going
to get back to that a little bit later
on a very big on on school choice can
you imagine we even have to talk about
parental control and having parents
basically having parents get involved we
have school systems that don't even want
to talk to the parents about their
children and you talk about changing
gender and things where the child can
make a choice and the child can be
unbelievably young the country has gone
sick it's gone sick and I don't like the
term work because I hear woke woke woke
you know it's like just a term that use
half the people can't even Define it
they don't know what it is right but you
look at these things like women getting
you know competed with with you know men
that were men he barely is able to keep
the sentence going and our men and
they're out there swimming and setting
records you see the records that are
being broken
records that lasted for 19 years of
being broken by you know 30 seconds
they're trying to win by a sixteenth of
a second for in swimming on one of the
events a sixteenth of a second they're
trying to win for years
and a guy comes along and breaks the
record by you know numbers that will
never be broken all right so you get it
just over transphobia confusion and
disorientation there
um someone and this was kind of a funny
moment someone in the crowd praised the
governor of Iowa Kim Reynolds and Trump
is just so insecure that he immediately
has to say hey it was thanks to me that
she won and uh they ought to look at his
past record by the way take a look at
his past record
Kim Reynolds for governor of Iowa
[Music]
thank you I hate to say it without me
you know she was not gonna win you know
that right I gave you a couple of them
without me they wouldn't have won uh but
uh it's me me it can't just be praised
for someone else who's doing a good job
and then um lastly here someone in the
crowd asks Trump hey when you become
president day one you know this growing
list of day one promises that are never
done uh what are you gonna do to bring
back respect for law enforcement in this
country uh the Mueller report uh the
fake dossier how about the dossier which
was written up by the Democrats all fake
stuff and uh a disgusting thing and I
had to go through a long time and still
we did more than just about any
president in history with all of that
stuff on my shoulders they tell me oh I
was a Russian agent okay I was a Russian
agent I used to say first I thought they
were kidding when I heard that I said yo
that's sort of funny I didn't know what
the hell I hadn't even spoken to anybody
in Russia you know they went through
five million phone calls and I didn't
make one call to Russia that was a
little bit bad but they didn't denounce
that they didn't talk about that totally
unintelligible word salad when asked
about respect for law enforcement we
have a very very corrupt system and it's
got to be and we need from the top we
need great people we need heads of the
FBI we need heads of the uh the top
people at the Department of Justice
right this is there you go so uh unable
to answer even a single question and now
we go to maybe the most interesting
moment from all of Trump's Iowa speeches
during one of Trump's speeches in Iowa
over the weekend
a voter confronts Trump about the
vaccines the very vaccines which Trump
takes credit for and takes a pride in as
one of his biggest accomplishments
during the covet Pandemic those vaccines
that his supporters mostly are against
and won't receive
a voter says we lost a lot of people
because you supported the Jab
and this gets super interesting take a
look at this
yeah well you know everybody wanted a
vaccine at that time and I was able to
do something that nobody else could have
done getting it done very very rapidly
but I never was a mandates I was I
thought the mandates were terrible
and
and you know there's a big portion of
the country that thinks that was a great
thing you understand that not a lot of
the people in this room but there's a
big but there is a big portion
some people think the vaccine was a good
thing you know I would have loved to
have seen Trump say when she says we've
lost a lot of people because you
supported the jab Trump goes yeah
I would have preferred Trump to say
what do you mean we've lost a lot of
people because I supported the job what
exactly are you talking about Force the
voter to say well hundreds of thousands
millions have died from the covet
vaccine now I think it's important given
the opportunity to remind everybody
there is still no credible evidence
about covid vaccine related deaths there
was a misleading report put out by a
group called The Institute for pure and
applied knowledge they used completely
bogus methods and assumptions to
estimate probably 300 000 people died
from the vaccine they used an excess
death sort of calculation what's funny
is they didn't even include the
possibility that the excess deaths were
from covid from the thing that was
actually killing people
uh there was a false claim that Pfizer
revealed data that
um death as a possible side effect was a
common thing when people were in the
test group The Trial group or whatever
um that's been completely debunked what
it relates to is that there are people
who died in the few months following
vaccination which you would expect from
groups of humans some people die for
reasons that have nothing to do with the
vaccine so the Pfizer one was a big
thing now it is true that people
occasionally die from common vaccines
they're insanely rare cases and they
usually involve a sort of known
theoretical risk of death and the real
numbers are so so so small a couple
examples anaphylaxis which is a really
severe allergic reaction after any
vaccine there can be anaphylaxis usually
happens within minutes of the vaccine
can be treated with epi Nephron
um the rate of anaphylaxis after
vaccination is believed to be somewhere
between 1 in 10 cases per million
vaccines administered and of course the
epinephrine shot uh will will save most
of those 1 to 10 per million there is
something called
intussusception which is a type of bowel
obstruction when you get the rotavirus
vaccine which is given to infants and
young kids really important to protect
against uh severe diarrheal disease
there can be a risk of intussusception
after the rotavirus vaccine one to five
cases per hundred thousand doses
administered uh GBS
Guillain-Barre syndrome very rare nerve
damage disorder can happen after the flu
shot the risk is about one to two cases
per million Doses and then you know you
can look at the yellow fever vaccine
there's something called y-e-l-a-v d
to severe reaction to the yellow fever
vaccine and
um that is important in some parts of
the world the risk of that is under one
case per 100 000 doses administered so
can people die after a vaccine yes is it
so so so rare absolutely is there any
proof that people are dying from the
covid vaccine there is not but this is
what we call when a trump voter
confronts Trump about the vaccine he
created and wants credit for this is
losing control of the monster you
created I've mentioned it before and
we'll have the clip of this interaction
on our YouTube channel on our tick tock
on our Instagram
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's continue our tour of this
weekend's 2024 Republican campaign
happenings Ron DeSantis suffered another
woke coma when asked at the roast and
ride event at which Mike Pence also
spoke we'll talk about Mike Pence's
speech tomorrow I think we're just not
going to have time today this was in Des
Moines Iowa uh DeSantis went into one
another one of these Comas where he uses
the word woke I mean I don't let's count
how many times he uses it in 30 seconds
[Music]
woke mind virus represents a war on the
truth so we will wage a war on the woke
we will fight the woke in education we
will fight the woke and the corporations
we will fight the woke in the halls of
Congress we will never ever surrender to
the woke mob we will make woke ideology
leave it to the Dustbin of History it's
gone
so that's seven wokes in the first 28
seconds there now has DeSantis ever
defined woke he tried we're going to
look at that a little bit later when we
also look at Nikki Haley's attempt I
think the really we'll we'll talk about
the definition of woke a little bit
later
hear what I want to mention and it's
particularly important if we want to
understand the DeSantis campaign the
whole anti-woke Crusade that the santis
is pushing is rooted in I'm not going to
say fascist ideology it's fascistic
ideology which wants to silence dissent
and uphold whatever right it used to be
we silenced descent and uphold white
supremacy when you look to some prior
fascists uh it could be for whatever
reason at this point we want to silence
Progressive voices or we want to silence
LGBT voices or whatever and so he's
using this fascistic fear-mongering and
of course misinformation to demonize
those who challenge desantis's narrow
and extraordinarily biased view of what
the world and how the country is
supposed to operate and so he will label
any attempt to teach or to learn about
history and reality of racism and
oppression and all these things he will
limit it that's what he does and of
course it completely ignores the
educational value the cultural value of
learning about those things and of
diversity and of inclusion he ignores
the harm that these policies have and
the the the the suppressive and
oppressive impact on speech that they
push forward and so the DeSantis
anti-woke obsession
is not only fascistic in its Origins I
believe it's also bad strategy because
it doesn't reflect the views or or
interests of even if you don't want to
say of most Americans of roughly half of
Americans according to recent polls a
majority of Americans support teaching
about racism support teaching slavery in
schools oppose Banning books that deal
with those issues a majority of
Americans more than ever before support
LGBT rights and immigration reform and
voting rights all of that stuff is
actually as popular or more popular than
any other positions on those issues and
so DeSantis ends up alienating himself
from mainstream public opinion and
Catering to a fringe base that's driven
by fear and resentment and scapegoating
and bigotry we know all this the
question is will obsessing about this
stuff allowed DeSantis to appear to be a
leader rather than just the demagogue
and if the voters of the Republican
Party want a demagogue they've got their
guy already and it's Trump so it's not
particularly good strategy totally a
laughing stock truly Ron desantis's wife
Casey DeSantis is stealing Donald
Trump's they came to me with tears in
their eyes routine so DeSantis is
already stealing the Joe Biden basement
line from Trump Casey DeSantis is now
stealing these stories just as a
reminder Trump often tells these stories
you know they came to me they said sir
and they were crying these were big
strong generals and then they said uh we
we don't have any we don't have any
bullets left Obama left the cupboards
bare Obama and we always wonder are
these stories real I think the answer is
probably not now Casey DeSantis is
taking a shot at one of these stories
like I have the responsibility to come
out here and say this because I see him
in front of the cameras and I see him at
home behind the cameras and I see him
with his kids six five and three he
never changes he never wavers he never
backed down he always always stands up
for what's right he does not take the
path of least resistance he doesn't
cower and it really is refreshing to see
that somebody is standing up for what is
Right standing up for the rights
Liberties livelihoods and happiness of
the people that he was voted to
represent and that was true in Spades
when you saw covid here we go I can tell
you stories of moms in the midst of
coven single moms coming up to me with
tears in their eyes because they didn't
know how they were going to be able to
put food on the table for their kids
they didn't know whether their children
were going to be able to get an
education to be able to live up to their
god-given potential but they were crying
they would go to they weren't even going
up to Ron DeSantis they were going up to
Casey DeSantis With Tears in their eyes
and crying listen is it possible someone
cried in Casey desantis's presence
during covert I mean sure uh do we in
general believe that everybody is
constantly crying in front of
politicians who clearly don't care about
them I I struggle to believe that this
is a legitimate story let me know what
you think let's now get to defining woke
here is Nikki Haley also running for the
2022 2024 presidential uh Republican
Presidential nomination she got herself
a nice little CNN Town Hall she was
asked to Define woke it did not go well
Define woke there's a lot of things I
mean you want to start with
girls fall
sport right now I mean all of these
things that are pushing what a small
minority want on the majority of
Americans it's too much it's too much I
mean the idea that we have biological
boys playing in girls Sports it is the
women's issue of our time is it my
daughter ran track in high school I
don't even know how I would have that
conversation with her how are we
supposed to get our girls used to the
fact that biological boys are in their
locker rooms okay so she goes off the
rails asked to Define woke she says woke
is stuff like biological Boys in girls
locker rooms now she's not certainly not
defining it she's giving examples of
things she believes are woke it's sort
of like if I said hey can you define
what a fruit is and you go well you know
you've got your banana
uh you've got your
you've got your cantaloupe right but
what's the definition of fruit and we
would say oh well the fruit is the seed
bearing structure in a flowering plant
formed from the ovary after flowering
now it's true that sometimes examples
might be more illustrative than some
kind of definition but these are the
people who say if you can't Define woman
there's something wrong with you here
was Ron DeSantis given an attempt to uh
given the opportunity to Define woke
just a few days ago we know what woke is
it's a form of cultural Marxism it's
about putting Merit and achievement
behind identity politics and it's
basically a war on the truth and is that
as an infected institutions that has
corrupted a lot of Institutions so
you've got to be willing to fight the
woke we've done it in Florida okay so
cultural Marxism was the santis's answer
so a couple different things the term
woke has been perverted I don't know
anyone on the left who still uses it
seriously because it's been perverted it
now just basically means anything
right-wingers don't like what woke meant
before it was perverted meant I am aware
of problems in society that might be
bigger than one person we might call
them structural problems and I think it
would be a nice thing to fix those
problems that was wokeness when the term
was used seriously they've now totally
perverted it cultural Marxism was
desantis's attempt to Define cultural
Marxism is a far-right anti-semitic
conspiracy theory that blames Jewish
German academics known as the Frankfurt
School for spreading movements like
identity politics and political
correctness as some kind of way to
manipulate and undermine western
civilization and Christian values that's
what cultural Marxism is it also
it uses the word Marxism
so it makes it sound like it's somehow
related to Marx but it's not it's a
misnomer it has nothing to do with the
economic and class analysis of Karl Marx
it also really misrepresents the ideas
of the frankfur Frankfurt School as well
like him or hate him the Frankfurt
School were a group of critical
theorists who analyzed the role of
culture and mass media and ideology in
society so cultural Marxism is like a
post-factual dog whistle appealing to
anti-Semitism and paranoia that's how
that's how DeSantis is defining woke
this is actually going to be a bigger
issue than we might think
because the longer that they continue
using woke in this way
the more it is going to seem like an
actual platform or proposal when it's
not it's a misunderstood talking point
that they don't even understand so we'll
get back to it in the coming days Nikki
Haley swinging a miss and certainly
striking out Ron DeSantis
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright I
don't want to spend a ton of time on
this just because she she's such a
despicable person and obviously a liar
that it's like how much time do I need
to spend reminding you that
congresswoman Lauren bobert is a liar
but this is actually sort of an
important story there was this debt
ceiling vote of course and Lauren bobert
is now claiming that the fact that she
didn't vote one way or the other on the
bill was a sort of protest because they
weren't letting her do her job and it's
this big moral stand that she's taking
except now video has been released of
Lauren bobert trying to Sprint into the
capital to vote she was just late she
just missed the vote that's all that
happened so let me give you the comings
and goings of this here's Lauren bobert
back in Colorado
explaining that she is protesting
against the debt ceiling Bill she's
against adding debt she tweeted quote
call it a protest there's no there's
absolutely no way to ever justify adding
another four to six billion dollars in
debt this is more DC self-created
garbage that I will always fight against
and here's the video that she put out
about this hey everyone
once again Washington's power machine
shoved a multi-trillion dollar bill down
our throats refused to allow debate or
amendments disregarded everything we
fought for in January to actually allow
representatives to do their jobs and
instead they served us up a crap
sandwich call it a no-show protest but I
certainly let every one of my colleagues
and the country know I was against this
garbage of a bill yeah it's a no-show
protest
except here's video
taken by CNN associate producer Morgan
rimmer of bobert trying to sprint in and
realizing being told the vote's over you
missed it does this look like someone
who's not trying to vote
there is Lauren bober
sprinting up the steps of the capital
to try to vote
this is a lie she is a liar it's
political theater but it is very low end
political theater Lauren bobert has
nothing interesting to add about the
debt ceiling she has no relevant
insights she has no particular
experience that makes her someone to
listen to on this issue she isn't even
important enough for anyone to bother
paying attention to whether she is or
isn't voting and she's turned all of it
into a big story about herself but it
was all a lie she just was late to vote
and then retroactively came up with this
stupid story
the only other thing I'll say is she won
by only 500 votes she can be defeated
she has an opponent Adam Frisch and it
would be great to defeat her in 2024.
Twitter is undeniably collapsing at this
point in time
The Defenders of Elon musk's takeover
insist everything is fine any user of
Twitter if you're paying attention you
can tell something is not right on the
platform we now have a new report
Twitter hit by a staggering
59 drop in U.S ad sales Twitter's Us ads
Revenue has plunged dramatically in the
wake of Elon musk's takeover of the site
according to the New York Times the
newspaper reports an internal Twitter
presentation showed the company's
American ad sales in the five weeks from
April 1 into early May were at 88
million dollars a whopping 59 percent
lower than the same period a year
earlier unnamed current and former
employees say Twitter's ad sales staff
are worried that advertisers may have
throttled spending out of concern about
an increase in hate speech and porn on
the platform along with a surge in
advertisements for cannabis products and
online gambling six Ad Agency Executives
say clients continue to limit Twitter
spending out of confusion about musk's
changes to the site as well as
inconsistent support from Twitter
meanwhile Twitter's head of brand safety
and AD quality will be leaving this was
announced three days ago this is AJ
Brown Twitter head of brand safety and
AD quality has decided to leave
additionally we found that twitters head
of trust and safety has resigned this is
Ella Irwin told Reuters Thursday she's
out she has faced criticism for lacks
protections against harmful content
since musk acquired the platform
apparently unable to do anything about
it she has also resigned so listen
um I I am actually I don't find this to
be a great thing you know I've been on
Twitter for a long time and spelled
spent time building a following and have
made some great contacts on Twitter and
Twitter as we know it has essentially
been destroyed the verified feed is now
useless because anybody can just pay
eight bucks to get verified I used to
you I know people like oh David that's
so elitist I would communicate with
other verified people on Twitter and the
verification serve to say this is really
that person I don't now have to wonder
is this AOC or is this the AOC parity
account that Elon Musk was signal
boosting that was a bad move
the new algorithmic for you feed I
looked at it today it was posts from
Michael Knowles Matt Walsh and Brigitte
Gabriel that's what for you was pitching
to me
um people who don't pay the eight bucks
are getting de-prioritized in the
algorithm they're admitting this this
isn't even me saying that Elon Musk said
paying gets you prioritized in the
algorithm so I'm really not posting much
and many people have written to me and
said David are you going to a different
platform I'm on Blue Sky but blue sky is
really really small I don't know whether
there's really going to be a replacement
to Twitter something really intangibly
bad is happening on Twitter and it only
is logical to believe that it is a
result of Elon musk's takeover because
all of this stuff happened since Elon
Musk took over could it be a correlative
thing and not causative I guess maybe
but it seems pretty clear what is going
on my hope is that it turns around
because I liked Twitter I I still like
Twitter as a platform
um but at this point it's just you know
every once in a while I'll put something
up there the engagements vary so so a
ton of trolls people I have to end up
muting and so on and so forth and even
though Elon Musk claimed that ad sales
were off the charts
they're not they're not and Twitter
truly is struggling there uh by one
report Twitter's value is down about
two-thirds since Elon Musk purchased it
we will follow it but so far not exactly
a heroic and inspiring tale we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David P here is a caller asking about
how can it be good to eat vegetables if
babies don't like them it's weird take a
listen to this
hi David in the context of evolution
yeah how is it possible that we eat
vegetables and fruits given
children's reactions to them and you
know it's like pulling teeth to get a
child's try a piece of what they used to
like throughout history
why did we eat
oh I think I think I know it's because
we have no other options available and
um
compared to anything else
you know if you're starving it's like
hunger is the best place okay I answer
my own question thanks a lot David for
for not doing anything useful to help
and leading me to my oh boy so anyway
how do vegetables make sense in terms of
human evolution and babies don't like
them listen my daughter likes every
vegetable and every fruit I mean sure
mango how can anybody not like a mango
but raspberry blackberry pear you know
everything
um I don't really know what the caller's
talking about how could it be I guess
the idea would be if if babies and
little kids instinctively reject fruits
and vegetables it would suggest that
evolutionarily blah blah blah well but
babies also don't forage for food on
their own so it doesn't really matter
it's a matter of whether the parents are
giving the babies fruits and vegetables
and it makes a lot of evolutionary sense
because they provide essential nutrients
and vitamins and minerals and
antioxidants so you know sugar that
gives us energy satisfies sweet cravings
and fruit and it seems to me that eating
fruits and vegetables is perfectly in
line with Evolution although it sounds
like the collar doesn't actually need my
help figuring it out I don't know uh if
you have anything you want to ask or say
you can call 219 to David P on the bonus
show today oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad we
will talk about a U.S fighter jet
response to an unresponsive aircraft
near Washington DC the aircraft
ultimately crashed near in Virginia what
happened there we will discuss Saudi
Arabia cutting oil production
specifically to increase prices this
time acting unilaterally some in the U.S
aren't happy what does it all mean we
will discuss it and lastly what's
happening with Disney is just so so
funny Disney continues to welcome LGBT
individuals and families as the battle
with Ron DeSantis continues to rage
folks I don't think this is a battle Ron
DeSantis has even a chance in hell of
winning all of those stories and more
when we are joined by producer Pat on
today's bonus show please sign up at
joinpakman.com you go a long way to
supporting the work we do and it feels
good to sign up and say I'm a David
Pacman show remember it's a great thing
just got an interesting email actually
about two women bonding on a flight
about their David Pacman show
memberships very interesting story
um sign up at joinpakman.com we'll see
you on the bonus show we are here all
week
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC